خطواتن عده تتخذها شركه ابل لفصل النظام
تشغيل الهاتف الخاص المحمول بها عن
الميزات التي تقدمها شركه الفابات الشركه
الام لجوجل ابل تخوض تجربتها منذ سنوات
بتصوير بتطوير كامل لبرامجها للسيامه
برامج البحث والاعلانات والخرائط الخاصه
بها هذه التطورات التي تعكس ابل عليها
ستكون
بمثل الذي يذوب في جوجل ليعلن حربا كانت
صامته لسنوات بين الطرفين هذه الحرب التي
بدات مع منافسه شرسه قبل سنوات حين
استحوذت جوجل على نظام تشغيل اندرويد
واصبحت منافسا شرسه لابل في سوق الهواتف
والاجهزه اللوحيه
[موسيقى]
ابل تعزز خدماتها لازاحه خدمات جوجل من
تقنياتها هل بالفعل يمكن استبدال صحه
تعبير تقنيات وخدمات ابل بجوجل الموجوده
اليوم
برضو نفس السؤال اذا طرحناه مهما كان هي
على تبني المستخدم
الى تطبيقات من تطبيقات اخرى صعب علينا
بعد التعود لسنوات وسنوات
نستخدم مثلا تطبيقات
ابل بدون ما نستخدم خرائط جوجل اللي مثلا
تعودنا عليهم
انعكس ايضا مساله تعزيز بنفس التطبيقات
وفصلها عن النظام الاساسي شيء جدا ممتاز
لكن دائما في معدله التقنيات والتطبيقات
هي اعلى تبني المجتمعات لها اكثر من اي
شيء
طيب فيصل
بين ابل ستور وجوجل بلاي ايهما افضل
الحين كل واحد من الاثنين عندهم كميه ضخمه
بالمليارات الى التطبيقات ولما نتكلم على
هذه الكميه هي تخدم شريحه ضخمه من الناس
بحسب احتياجاتهم لما نيجي نقارن بين
النجارين هتلاقونا المقارنه جدا صعبه ولكن
لما نجي ونخيب المستخدم على حسب
احتياجاتهم هنعرف ان احنا نوصل لشركه مثلا
لو تكلمنا عن اللوحيه اللي من شركتها انا
عارف انه لايك اقرب لما تجرهم انه فيها كم
ممتاز من تطبيقات الخاصه بالايفادات بس لو
نيجي نشوف اللوحيات حقات نفس الاندرويد
والاجهزه والانظمه اللي تشتغل عليها هذه
اللوحيات يمكن هنلاقي التخسيس الخاص ونقدر
نقول النوعيه الجيده من التطبيقات زي ما
سوي تعبان وهناجي الكفه على طول راحت نفس
الشيء في الجوال على حسب نوع الجوال
والمقارنه والمستخدم هنلاقي واحد من
المتاجر افضل للمستخدم منها الثاني طب
اضافه الى الخرائط كانت الجبهه الثانيه
للمعركه بين جوجل وابل هي محرك البحث هل
يمكن لابل ان توفر نفس المحرك بنفس الجوده
ونفس السرعه لجوجل جميل جدا
كبيره انهم بالفعل يجيبوا شيء يبدل او
يخلي شريحه من المستخدمين يستبدله جوجل
ليش يقول هذا الكلام فعليا انا تكلمنا على
سفاري المتصفح الرسمي من شركه ابل اللي
موجود على كل اجهزهم هذا المتصفح في
الاعدادات يقدروا يحطوا احد مواقع الرسميه
اللي من خلال عمليه البحث بسهوله تخصيص
هذا الموقع وتغييره الى جوجل الى اي موقع
ثاني اي موقع يحتاج تدخل المستخدمين يعني
لما يدخل ويعدله الاعدادات فبالتالي
هتلاقوا الشريحه ضخمه مستخدمين ما حيسووا
هذا الشيء طبيعي فهمم اول ما يجي جوالي
هيفتحه يبقى خلاصنا فبالتالي هذه الامر
ممكن جدا